josh tomlin his first start since last
september when the braves faced kansas
city trey turner leads off for the
nationals pitch
line drive center ender retreat still
going that ball curling away from him
and he got there a step shy of the wall
that ball was smoked
and turner's retired four out number one
adam eaton is the nationals right
fielder
swing and a miss eaton didn't get that
tomlin's first strikeout two up two down
and here's soto
on the ground camargo to his right josh
tomlin mows down the nets in one two
three order austin both the 28 year old
from redmond washington
and the university of washington on the
mound for the nationals faces dansby
swanson three for six last night and
this one's shot toward the gap in left
center that's gonna get down between
soto and robles that's gonna roll all
the way to the wall dansby's got two
thinking about three but he'll throw out
an anchor and he leads off with a first
inning double boy he is red hot and the
braves mixing things up early against
the nationals
so both in immediate trouble as freddie
stands in
line in a right that's a base head
dansby had to hold up for a moment the
braves have first and third nobody out
travis darno
and there's a drive hit toward left soto
long run still going not gonna get there
that's off the base of the wall one run
scores freddy on his way to third three
straight atlanta hits to start the game
and it's one to nothing
now it's eric thames with two outs
and a ball hammered up the middle it
gets down around third suzuki
and kurt chugging home to tie the game
on eric thames
fourth rbi and his
second straight night with a run better
than that boy eric thames that's clutch
eaten with a line drive to left center
field headed toward the gap that's going
to be down split the outfielders and
ciarte cuts it off on the warning track
and eaton will jog into second with a
one-out double
see how carefully the braves attack juan
soto and the answer is not at all
because he just received an intentional
walk so soto first in first along
cabrera
as druva waiting for that one he hits it
hard beyond the second baseman adam
eaton coming around
the nets are on top
that's one way to make teams pay for
walking that man right there
and as jubal cabrera continues his
amazing rbi hitting two out walk keeps
the inning alive for johan camargo
hone it down and hit the other stuff
which he did right there that's headed
for the right field corner eaton will
play that off the fence it dies at the
wall heading toward third is duvall he
was going to come around third the ball
got away from garcia no further advance
and johan camargo got a pitch to hit and
didn't miss it
so the braves need to hit need a big hit
let's see if riley can provide it he
walked his first time up
swaying in a shot base hand one run is
in here comes camargo flying around
third big hit for riley throws cut off
he's in a run down between first and
second
and he'll be tagged out
but boy did the braves need that
austin riley with a big rocket to left
field brings home duval and camargo the
braves have a 3-2 lead freeman is
singled and walked he's extended his
hitting streak to five games
fly ball wallop deep right field freddie
freeman has headed to the chop house he
missed his pitch once but didn't miss
the second one and the braves now lead
it
five to two on freddy freeman's fourth
home run
the left-hander for the braves out of
the bullpen 29 year old former rocky
tyler metzik
on a ball away turner slaps it to right
and he finally won't be denied he's got
to be thinking three here
look at him fly around the bases
trey turner leadoff triple who had him
eat one for two of the double he got the
nat started on their run in the third
and he's gonna go oppo again to bring
home trey turner adam eaton just put his
best consecutive at bats of the season
together
not many have been hotter than juan soto
soto slaps a base hit
coming around third adam eaton will
score easily and the nets are swinging
opposite field hits beautifully three in
a row here in the fifth inning just like
that it's five to four the gnats have
the bases loaded john gomes is the
batter now
breaking ball up and a base hit
everybody's going to move up 90 feet
and the nationals are back even at five
well quite a mess for aj minter to
inherit base is loaded one out but he
does have a lefty lefty matchup with
eric thames
eric thames pulls it freddie freeman
knocks it down the only play he has is
right next to him cabrera scores and
thames hit it hard to put the nets on
top 6-5
tying her on a board bottom of the fifth
for riley
out to center road lays long way to go
and he gets there to pull it back in
with a little snow cone at the end
unbelievable
i mean that's a two-run home run it's
seven to six braves victor robles goes
over the fence
to rob austin riley one of the best
catches you'll see this year
that's trying to add on here in the
eighth
and a lead off double by victor robles
who's been all over the place tonight
that's a good-looking line drive the
other way roble's around third inciarte
up with it victor heading home
safe
and the nets
have a 7-5 lead that's a beautiful piece
of hitting man so ozuna the final hope
for atlanta in the eighth first and
third now two outs
a little pop into shallow right eaton
was playing over there he's near the
line and he's got it and a good job by
finnegan to come on and strike out
darneau and get ozuna to pop out two out
of the top of the ninth inning but eric
thames is coming up
oh he waited for the breaking ball and
it's a base hit
garcia around third to score
three run lead the runners move up as
the ball gets mishandled
eric thames what a great job of patient
hitting right there and the nationals
now have an 8-5 lead